so violence is way up all around the
country criminal violence
cities like chicago are setting records
for violent crime
every weekend so you're in much more
danger than you have been
in a very long time decades what's the
government doing to protect you what is
congress doing to protect you nothing
but they are protecting themselves
you'll be happy to know at your expense
the us capitol police have just
announced their opening regional offices
in tampa florida san francisco
california more offices are planned
no one in congress seems to be objecting
to this they defund your police and then
make you pay for more police for them
ron johnson is the united states senator
from wisconsin one of the bravest people
in that body
we're happy to have him on tonight
senator thanks so much for coming on
so i it's hard to miss the contrast here
people are going without police
protection but the congress has decided
it needs more
you're right tucker let's face it i
support law enforcement unlike democrats
who only support law enforcement to
protect them
and the fact matters on january 6 the
line officers did an exemplary job of
protecting
uh members of congress but their
leadership
congressional leadership capitol hill
police leadership utterly
failed those line officers as well as
their mission and so now they want to
expand their mission
and be on the capitol hill they ought to
focus on
what they failed to do on january 6 and
they ought to focus on the mission of
protecting the capital
and members of congress in the capitol
not not out in the states
protecting members of congress should be
a state uh
responsibility the states should protect
their their elected representatives not
capitol hill police
we don't need another federal agency
doing what you know is outrageously
being done to you
surveilling and snooping on american
citizens
i mean the imagery here is is make
honestly it's making people radical so
they tell us
you're not allowed to have a wall to
protect the national border
because that's racist but then congress
builds a wall around its own office
building to protect
it from american citizens i mean i
wonder if people inside the building can
see what this looks like from the
outside
it doesn't look good at all a lot of us
did but again the democrats
liked that narrative that that defense
should have been taken down for sure the
day after the inauguration but
it was allowed to stand because it
perpetuated that false narrative
that 75 million americans who voted for
president trump were suspected domestic
terrorists
right and the capital need to be
protected against them and that's
what's happening here and what's your
experience right now is really
what i've been uh delving into for the
last six years the
the deep state you know lord acton said
that power corrupts absolute power
corrupts
absolutely and what we're finding is
these agencies by and large are
populated with people who support the
democrat cause
democrats are more than happy to support
these agencies
the intelligence committee yep tucker
i've had intelligence operations
performed against me false intelligence
products created
classified and then leaked this is
beyond outrageous i want to help you
continue to expose us i appreciate
your courage and exposing it it's the
only hope we have of fixing this problem
yeah i mean it's it's criminal and it's
terrifying i appreciate you coming
tonight senator ron johnson wisconsin
thank you
have a good night hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else